julia do you remember what happened
daddy was taking me to shelly's house
and this car hit us really fast what
would you tell
six-year-old dakota on set for the first
time
i honestly remember it like it was
yesterday
you know they gave me all the all the
props to take home and play with and i
literally thought it was christmas day
can you believe it's been 20 years since
dakota's acting debut on er
she sounded all grown up in her first
e.t interview
i always wanted to be an actress now 26
dakota along with luke evans and daniel
bruell
is back for season two of the alienist
which airs sunday on tnt
dakota is a detective trying to solve a
baby's kidnapping
we must see and not be seen why did you
want to get the gang back together
the three of us really became close and
get along so well so it was another
excuse to spend time together and um
and and get to continue this story
it's like an endless treasure that that
show
next up for luke he's headed down under
to star with nicole kidman and melissa
mccarthy in
nine perfect strangers from the writer
of big little eyes
we're gonna have a very intimate uh five
months
in australia once we've done our
quarantine
i think it's gonna be a really fun
experience
you